- Hi, I'm Mike Minecki.
And I'm going to be
talking to you about how
organizations and how Yale might be
using machine learning to create
content faster and smarter.
This started out as an
internal presentation,
and it was a little bit more lowkey but
On Franz's advice, stealing from Michael,
Mike Connery from his
presentation yesterday.
AI is set to transform industries
including communications,
it is expected to be a
1.4 to 2.6 trillion dollar
transformation for just the
marketing communications
industry in the next few years.
And it's one of those
technologies that seems like
it's in the future or
something that's going to be
coming down the pipe or
something that's frankly in
science fiction, but
really its something that
organizations are using today in
their communication plans and there's a
lot of opportunities right away.
So I'm Mike Minecki, I'm the director of
technology at Four Kitchens
and Four Kitchens we're a
digital agency that creates
websites, apps, and software for
organizations that need
to tell important stories.
We're been around for 13 years,
have severed a sophisticated
clientele, including Yale,
as their trusted digital
partner trivialize and
exceed their goals.
Four Kitchen's web shifts believe
that creating a website is
like preparing a feast, it requires a
team of people which specialize in
complimentary skills working in concert to
create something that
lots of people will enjoy,
it's part art, part science,
and it's all about preparation.
`So what I'm gonna try
to dive into today is
defining a few terms
around machine learning and
artificial intelligence,
talking a little bit about what,
how these organizations
are doing things that
you would only expect to see
in science fiction today,
diving into some of the ways that it
can be utilized here
at Yale or on any CMS,
and then really hopefully get
people thinking about how it
might be used in the future.
So, what I'm not gonna talk about is
I'm gonna stick only to
the editorial process and
how it really effects editors.
But three key areas where
it really where there are
huge opportunities in mark with
being utilized today are in
personalization, that's probably the
one thing people first
think of when they think of
how AI and content kind of go together,
the other one is in analytics,
excuse me, and in chatbots.
Those, each one of those
could be its own presentation,
so that's really the reason
where I'm leaving it at today.
And then also, everybody
works at the CMS knows that it
doesn't get nearly as much love as
some of those other things.
So just to kind of define some terms,
Machine Learning so it's
a, it's a from Wikipedia,
it's a category of algorithm that
allows software applications
to become more accurate in
predicting outcomes without
being explicitly programmed.
It's really kinda bringing
statistics into the
things you traditionally think
computer programming is doing and it
opens up some interesting
opportunities because of that.
Artificial Intelligence I mean
is kinda the blanket term but
they get used interchangeably,
depending on whose speaking
and who the audience is.
Honestly like lots of
technical people will use
machine learning and marketing
people are gonna use AI,
cause it sounds cooler.
And then a really big part
of this and a lot of the
opportunities that are
coming from content come
from natural language processing.
So that's artificial intelligence that
helps computers understand, interpret and
manipulate human language.
And dive into more how
it does that as we go.
One way that helped me
understand kinda the
difference between the
machine learning and
kinda like what we traditionally
think of programming is
to kinda compare the two;
So in programming, when you're
in computer programming you
have data, so you have like
data coming from a data base or
something else or input by a user,
and you have rules so like those are the
functions you write as a programmer,
like if than statements and all that.
And then you combine those together and
you get out predictable output.
Because it's written by humans it's
mostly predictable output,
but ya know there are ways to
write tests to make it better.
And the rules are written by humans,
so like when you're
programming a computer like
there's like you can
kinda trace back in and
step through it and understand
exactly what it's doing.
In contrast, machine learning is data,
so whatever data you're
putting into the system,
and then statistical models
that output results with
confidence scores and that's
a lot different than the
programming which is
really deterministic but in
AI and the outputs of AI
you'll get a result that is
50 percent one and 50 percent another or
90 percent one and 10 percent of another.
And the models, the statistical
models their built on
examples and there's a
black box element to it,
so you're not actually
like manipulating the
outputs directly and you really
can step through them and
easily understand the logic
that is going into it,
which is kind of a fundamental
difference between them, it's
what opens up a lot of the
opportunities that AI opens up
but it also creates its
own set of problems.
So what is it good at,
it's good at finding and
following patterns and then
making predictions based on
those patterns.
And those predictions and
those patterns they can be in
things that are really squishy,
like what's inside of an image,
it can also be really or like
what somebodies trying to
say when their using words to communicate.
And making predictions
so like based on the
huge amount of data that you put in,
if you put this one piece of
data into it you expect it
to come out this way.
It gets better over time
as models are refined and
we're all kinda experiencing this as it
goes particularly with like
big companies like Google as
it's getting better at
reading our email and
understanding like what we're trying to
say when we're talking to our
Google Home, things like that.
And really the biggest
fundamental difference and
biggest fundamental opportunity that the
machine learning and AI
provides is that it's the
first time that computers and
content management systems can
really see into the complex
stuff that is images or
like human to human communication.
Before, sorry, before that was like
content management systems just is like
a place where you'd put stuff but it
really has no idea what's in there and
it kinda doesn't care.
And this is the first time where your
content management system can start to
actually read what you write.
So like there are some risks or there are
things that they're not good at.
The building of models
takes time and iteration,
so because its not
deterministic it takes like
creating models, testing
them out seeing what the
outputs are like and experimentation.
It can very easily amplify bias and
I'm sure everybody here
has heard stories about how
facial recognition doesn't
work with people of color and
things like that, and
that's a very real concern.
And the other one is that
to really get good it
requires very vast datasets
and constant cultivation.
And for most small
organizations like those are
kinda like the stumbling
blocks and where AI and
machine learning don't
become viable solutions,
but there's lots of ways
to sorta tap into the
work that companies like
Google and Microsoft are
doing in this space to get access to
those really big datasets and
sorta the outputs of them.
So, Cassie Koz--man polish,
you'd think id be good at
pronouncing that but I
can't so I'm gonna give up.
Puts it this way, are you in
the business of baking bread?
Or making ovens?
All right and in this case the
ovens are being made by
Google, and by Microsoft,
and you're kinda putting stuff into it and
ya know putting dough into
it and getting bread back.
That's a good way to look at it.
So as I said before content
management systems today
don't know and really don't
care what you put in them.
They might have some
rules around the number of
characters that a piece of content has,
but if it's a story of birds
or if it's a story about
what happened last week at a
sports game it really doesn't
know unless you tell it,
unless you tag it, right?
What changes with AI
and machine learning is
for the first time like the
content management system can
really read and see
what's in your content.
And that seems kinda
futuristic but we're like
literally living with this
stuff in our daily lives,
more so probably than we are
living with this stuff in
our CMS's.
So major publishers are
already writing content that's
being published on their publications in
their print publications even that is
100 percent created by machines,
so the Washington Post has
a bot called Heliograph and
what it does is write summaries of
little league games across the country and
that's a beat that nobody
could really keep up with
and they wouldn't be able
to support otherwise,
but with AI they're able
to take the data from the
events, meaning like who won, who lost,
how many people were on base, et cetera
and write a story about
that based on a template.
Forbes has Bertie, which is a
new content management system
and what it does is it uses
machine learning and AI to
suggest better headlines
and find images that are
relevant to the content
that's being written so
they eliminate some of the menial tasks.
And then Bloomberg, Kenneth famously has
what they call kinda ominously Cyborg,
which takes financial
statements from companies and
creates news articles based on those.
So these are things that
are happening right now,
these are articles that
you are reading today.
The last part is that I wanna mention is
called Radar from the BBC,
and what it does is it
creates localized content to
make it more relevant and
more poignant for people in
different parts of England.
So if its a story about homelessness,
when it gets to the part
about statistics and
you're in Bristol,
it will talk about the
homelessness problem in Bristol.
And if you're in London,
it will talk about the
homelessness problem,
at least the statistics from London to
make that story more
relevant to you as the user,
which I felt was one
most fascinating sort of
applications of this.
Another place that this
is just showing up that is
kinda surprisingly effective
is in Google Photos,
so if you type into the
search bar almost any word in
Google Photos you'll get back
your photos that have been
tagged by Google for that word.
So here I look for pink,
if you look for dogs,
you could look for girls,
if you look for China or
Japan all those things come
up without any tagging on
my part or any interaction and if
you use Google Photos you
might have noticed that
there is a aspect of
it these days where it
kinda puts together
stories for you based on
images that go together and so it's
kinda helping you create
content without you having to
actually sit there and
organize and go through all the
photos and figure out which
ones are the good ones or
which ones go together.
It's also able to help you write,
does anybody here
besides me use Grammarly?
Yeah, a few, yeah I mean
it works it works well it
has relevant suggestions.
It reads content that you puts into it
and kinda integrates with
your Gmail and your editor and
things like that and this is a
similar kinda lower cost
thing called Hemingway.
And it's not just low hanging fruit,
it's looking for sentences
that are too long,
it's also looking for words
that are less effective,
and elevating your writing and not just,
excuse me, locking it into a set of rules.
Google's also working on
API moderation tools with
the New York Times to help cut down the
amount of toxicity in
the comments that are
made on articles, so
with this API they are
creating tools that
automatically give feedback to
writers and also provide
ways for moderators to
more quickly engage with the content.
So that's kinda like AI
in the broader world and
what's happening kinda outside
of our little ecosystem.
There are a number of
Drupal Modules that do
some nascent things but
like nothing nearly as
interesting honestly as some of the
things we talked about here.
One of them that's a really
low hanging fruit and
probably a frustration that everybody in
this room has had is creating
automatic alternative text,
there's also a very nascent
Google Cloud vision integration
that pulls in the tagging capabilities and
will actually tag your
images that you upload to
Drupal with all the same tags
that I was talking about in
Google Photos.
So if you upload a picture of a girl or a
picture that has the color pink in it in
your CMS those will also be tagged so
you can more easily find them
and attach them to content.
There's also a set of tools
called intelligent content tools
and they require installing
Python and some flasks and
stuff like that but once
you get it running it'll
actually do automatic summaries for you,
which is pretty fascinating
and pretty interesting.
I haven't played around with it directly,
but it does look like it
does what it says on the box.
And this is just the start
so in a way I think it's
not that like they're
AI isn't being used for
content creation it's that
these tools kinda aren't
filtering down into the
layer that we live in, right?
So, next I want to jump
into a little bit of
like what these API's are like,
and what can be leveraged
and where we can kinda go
immediately in the near future.
And because this is something
we've been thinking about,
we created a demo called Happygram.AI
and you can actually try
it out later today and
what it does is it collects
a happy moment from you,
and then illustrates it using images from
Unsplash using some of the
API's that I'm talking about.
It's kinda a fun way to see
what is potentially possible,
but also showcases how you
can use these technologies to
make content creation more streamlined.
So I'm gonna be talking about the
tools that Google provides but all the
cloud providers including AWS,
and Microsoft Azure, and Google,
and IBM Watson all have
these capabilities and
they're very comparable between them.
There's kinda subtle
differences in the capabilities,
subtle differences in what
they do and pricing but like
it's really interchangeable
depending on yeah
which platform your on
they're probably available.
So the first one is the
Google Natural Language Processing tools,
and what they do is that
they give you a lot of
analysis of text that you put into it.
So they analyze sentiment
so telling you how
positive or negative a piece of content is
so they're useful for things
like moderation of comments,
also in trying to understand
customer interactions with you.
But also can be a tool
for writers if they're to
be able to kinda provide
them with feedback about the
content that they're writing, right?
If they think that they're
writing something happy but
Google comes back and says
it's not really that happy,
that could be a sign that
there's a different way to
word things.
It provides a very
in-depth analysis of the
parts of speech and what
content is about but
then also how the different
words are linked together and
you have a very detailed
set of tools to be
able kinda pull out phrases and
associations of words in it.
There's a very global
content classification that
happens and you can see
like in Google there's like
links to the Wikipedia
articles and et cetera.
And also it provides the
most salient topics in
a piece of text and seeing this in
action is pretty impressive
because it's not like
we're kinda used to that with key words or
with a search or something like that,
but this is different so this is
what the content is really about and it's
prioritized based on how
important the nouns or
the subjects or the
entities as it calls it
are in the parts of speech.
The next API that's probably
the most useful out of
these and the lowest
hanging fruit that's kinda
immediately available and also really easy
because there's already
a Google integration,
is an API that classifies
the contents of image it
extracts objects from the images.
And I'll just move to the
slide with puppies anyway.
And it does a surprisingly
good job at this so
the things that like impress
me when I tried this out is
not that it finds the dog
but that it tags all three of
the dogs that are in this,
so two of the dogs you
can't see their faces,
they're looking away and the back one like
ya know, like it's almost
questionable whether it's
a cat or not, right?
The other thing that it finds is
that these are Labrador
Retrievers, which is
actually questionable in some ways but is
surprisingly accurate.
And then finally, that it
identifies that they're in
a kennel, and to me that's
kinda interesting because
you can't really tell that
the shape of a kennel or
something like that it's just I guess,
dogs with vertical bars in front of it
you know, have a very high probability of
being in a kennel.
So I mean in digging into these things,
and you can try them
out on their website it
is surprisingly powerful
and surprisingly accurate.
The last tool is probably
the most powerful and the
one that can provide the
biggest advantages to
content creators.
And its called Auto ML. And what it is,
it is a tool that takes
all the complexity out of
building your own machine
learning models and
gets it out of your way.
It works by you tagging your content,
a portion of it as the
learning model that it's
going to use, and then uploading
all of your content and
then just running algorithm through it.
You can see when you try
the demo out later today,
we used it to categorize
happy moments and there is
about seven categorize and it's
right almost every single time.
Which is fascinating
and that can be used to
take content that your
editors are putting in and
tag it with your taxonomy.
It can also be used to tag
it with a taxonomy or a
range of taxonomies that would be
completely pedantic and a
huge burden on your users so
I don't know if anybody here has like a
complicated taxonomy that there's like
fights around well does it
really belong in this or
does it belong in that and one person is
tagging things one way
but then another person is
tagging things another way
and it creates a mess and
makes the content difficult to find.
Using this tool, that
can all be automated and
editors can just go back to
just writing and not having to
worry about all of that types of content.
The other thing that it
can really help with is
with SEO, so being able
to take content and
automatically attach all
the metadata that Google or
Facebook is looking for
and take that out of
the writer's way.
So those are some of the different ways,
so those are some of the
things that are available.
But broadly what can it do?
So it can automate menial tasks,
so taking things like classification,
writing metadata,
attaching alt. text out of
the writers and content
creators day to day.
Even starting to do things
like summarize text.
It can also combine data with templates in
a much smarter way than you can now.
So right now you can sort of say that like
okay well this is gonna be content,
this is gonna be an
image and you kinda like
you put it into places
and it all fits together.
But instead now that can
go a layer deeper and
do something like the BBC where instead of
talking about you can
localize the content and
talk about statistics that are relevant to
the users or write one article,
use it in different schools
across the campus and
replace the relevant
information intelligently.
It can also provide very deep analysis of
the content and very unbiased
analysis of the content.
So tools like Hemingway and Grammarly
can provide feedback to writers
about how their writing is,
how effective it is, and how its working.
But it can also provide an entry point to
all the media that's being
used across campus and
centralize it and tag
it in ways that make it
useful to other parts of the campus.
So like when that, like going back to the
picture of the puppies inside the kennel,
probably very likely that if you have a
very disciplined content creation team if
they were uploading that
image that they would tag it
as dogs maybe tag it as puppies but it's
unlikely that, and where
they took it and things like
that probably, but it's unlikely
that they would actually
tag that image with the fact
that they're in a kennel.
That's kinda like a weird detail,
that Google picks up
on but if it wasn't an
article about kennels that
would probably never come up in
the mind of the content creator, right?
But here, its just very
pedantically and very
deeply sort of looking at what's there and
comparing it to things
that he'd seen before and
telling you what it thinks is there.
Another way that this
can be leveraged is to
provide suggestions to
improve content and take the
analytics data that is coming in and
provide suggestions as to
what kinds of headlines or
how headlines can be re-worded so
that they're more effective
when the content goes out.
And then finally a deep
categorization and a
very unbiased categorization of content.
So these are all the things
that like are possible or
can be done with machine learning and AI.
But there's one very big caveat,
that when creating models
or putting information into
a machine learning model it is
imperative that you really
look very deeply into
what you're putting into it because it's a
black box it doesn't lend
itself to easy scrutiny.
It's very easy to create not
just one piece of content or
one image that's biased
or that doesn't speak to
everyone but really kinda create
that problem across campus
and with when you're doing
things like making suggestions to
improve content or suggesting images that
can really reinforce the
bias' that are made by the
people who are creating
those models, right?
And it'll happen in subtle ways and
it'll also happen on a
much grander scale than
just one person writing one article.
And that's why ethics and AI
really kinda go together as a
conversation, it comes up in
the news this way but it's
not a FUD and its not an exaggeration,
like this is literally is a tool to
automate and disseminate bias.
Google and all the other
and Amazon both have
extensive portions about their ethics and
how they're approaching
it and it's gonna work if
you're kinda diving into this stuff to
really look at how they're
approaching this and the
mistakes that they've already made.
That's it!
(applause)
(clears throat)
(soft vibrational music)